[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend hinein an diesem
pfingstsonntag dem fünfzigsten tag der
osterzeit dem 102 tag eines krieges
mitten in europa der heute wieder neu
eskaliert und zwar auf dem schlachtfeld
und in worten ein ende ein ausweg
weiterhin nicht absehbar die ukrainische
hauptstadt kiew erlebt die schwersten
luftangriffe seit wochen es gab heute
morgen zweieinhalb stunden sirenenalarm
dort und russlands präsident wladimir
putin mit einer neuen düsteren warnung
an den westen sollte die ukraine waffen
mit großer reichweite bekommen dann so
sagt er wörtlich werden wir daraus die
entsprechenden schlüsse ziehen und
unsere mittel der vernichtung einsetzen
um jenen objekten schläge zu versetzen
die wir bisher nicht angreifen
wir gehen so johannes hano live in der
ukraine und johannes wie wird denn so
einer drohung eine warnung aus moskau in
der ukraine aufgenommen
also erst mal hat der ukrainische
generalstab schon die ganze woche davor
gewarnt dass die russischen streitkräfte
zu einer neuen strategie übergehen und
zwar massive luftangriffe auf zivile
infrastruktur
genau das geschieht im moment wir haben
sehr viele cruise missile attacken
gehabt die ganze woche auch in odessa es
wurden brücken zerstört es wurden
kornspeicher zerstört der gäste wurde
ein riesen kornspeicher in die luft
gejagt und da fragt man sich natürlich
was meint in der russische präsident
damit dass er jetzt ziele angreifen die
er noch nicht angegriffen hat auch
praktisch alles angegriffen und da
bleibt nicht mehr allzu viel übrig viele
spekulieren dass als nächstes in dieser
drohung gemeint sein könnte der
präsidentenpalast in kiew das ist
natürlich reine spekulation aber er hat
es ja schon versucht er hat ja schon mal
spezialkräfte nach geschicktem den
ukrainischen präsidenten umbringen zu
lassen das hat nicht geklappt und so
denken viele dass das möglicherweise ein
ziel sein könnte johannes die situation
aktuell ist unübersichtlich klar ist es
gibt erbitterte kämpfe viele tote auf
beiden seiten und beide seiten erhoffen
sich vorteile ist das jetzt die
situation die in den nächsten wochen
auch genau so bleiben wird
das wird mit sicherheit so bleiben denn
von ukrainischer seite ist eine
niederlage völlig ausgeschlossen der
präsident hat gesagt sie kämpfen bis sie
gewinnen werden wenn man hier die
menschen fragt ist es auch völlig klar
man wird keine niederlage akzeptieren
das ist ein no-go wie man sagt für die
menschen hier sie haben gesehen dass sie
mario pohl passiert ist in butter in
ihrem team die haben gesagt russland
will uns vernichten russland will uns
auslöschen für uns ist das ein
existenzkampf und ich glaube das ist
etwas was wir in deutschland nicht so
richtig begriffen haben die menschen
hier sind nicht bereit einen frieden zu
schließen mit pudding den man nicht
glaubt weil man weiß sein ziel ist es
sie zu vernichten als nation und auch
als volk sozusagen und das wird man
niemals hinnehmen machen dass herzlichen
dank
und was macht das alles mit denen die
eigentlich fürs leben lernen sollten und
jetzt mit dem tod konfrontiert sind
morgen beginnt in der ukraine für die
meisten die letzte schulwoche vor den
langen ferien drei monate dauern die sie
werden dieses jahr wenig haben von
unbeschwerter sommerzeit und niemand
kann den kindern sagen was danach kommt
zdf-reporterin alissa jung ist in
lemberg sie berichtet aus der
deutsch-ukrainischen schule wo sie eine
lange tradition haben und sich die
zukunft nicht nehmen lassen
ich sitze hier mit meinem freund andré
hier sitzt
und das war vor dem krieg seit drei
monaten sind skiathos lauf und seine
mitschüler der ukrainisch deutschen
schule in lemberg wieder im online
unterricht
viele sind geflohen und verstreut auf
der ganzen welt polen norwegen
deutschland trotzdem lernen sie zusammen
innerhalb von einer woche haben wir den
online unterricht im krieg organisiert
meine kollegin und ich haben seit dem
nicht eine stunde versäumt wenn sie
nicht unterrichten knüpfen sie hier
tarnnetze für die ukrainische armee kurz
vor dem russischen angriff haben die
schüler noch im keller schießen geübt
wir hatten hier also training wenn wir
also mit
da ahnten sie noch nicht wie lange wie
blutig dieser krieg werden würde dass er
ihr leben von einem auf den anderen tag
auf den kopf stellt die atoss läuft
hätte nun kurz vor dem schulabschluss
eigentlich die unbeschwerte zeit seines
lebens vor sich mit dem werk von hat
geändert glaube ich seine heimatstadt
lemberg ist zwar bislang verschont
geblieben
doch auch sie hat sich durch den krieg
verändert das sind die reste eines
russischen zerstörten flugzeugs ich bin
sehr stolz dass wir das gemacht haben
und jetzt können wir das sehen dass wir
nicht gewinnen
das hofft er zumindest trotzdem die
angst ist geblieben vor allem vor dem
was noch kommen könnte
nach der schule werde ich in uni
studieren hoffe dass sich
in dem krieg nicht
teilnehmen werde hoffe ich dass diese
super ich habe angst dass zu machen das
schwierigste für skater / zu verstehen
dass menschen aus seinem land sterben
müssen auch zivilisten kinder einfach so
ohne grund
ja es ist auch nicht zu verstehen
der 16 jährige macht übrigens dort in
lemberg einen abschluss der auch in
deutschland gelten würde aber er will
nicht weg und ich hoffe so sagt er
unserer reporterin dass all meine
cleveren freunde auch wieder
zurückkommen wir brauchen jeden schlauen
kopf
wie drummer traumatische erlebnisse ein
ganzes leben prägen können das zeigen
wir ihnen jetzt mitten in deutschland
eine andere generation
es sind menschen die heute genau 70
jahre danach noch immer nicht darüber
hinweg kommen dass die ddr-führung sie
damals zwangsweise aus ihren häusern
vertrieb das ganze lief unter dem
menschenverachtenden stasi decknamen
aktion ungeziefer katrin lindner
berichtet
jürgen ebel geht dort lang vor eins das
wohnhaus seiner familie stand heute
liegen nur noch die reste und am sand
und dann ist dort
ist das fundament noch drin mal so hier
in etwa als sohn des bürgermeisters in
roetgen wisch wächst er auf einem wurf
im heutigen brandenburg auf bis zum 12 6
begreift es nicht
das ist
das ist sowas gegeben hat er war dabei
als zwölfjähriger vor 70 jahren muss die
familie die über generationen hier ihren
bauernhof hatte innerhalb von stunden
ich bin von der schule nach hause
gekommen kam hier auf dem hof und wann
ihr leute die meine mutter weinte und
sagte was ist ja wir müssen hier weg und
das war also für mich unvorstellbar auf
veranlassung von spanien beschließt der
ministerrat der ddr am 26 mai 52 die
sperrung der innerdeutschen grenze
unmittelbar zuvor hatten die
bundesrepublik und westmächte die
souveränität westdeutschlands vereinbart
die ddr lässt auf rund 1400 kilometern
einen zehn meter breiten streifen an der
grenze roten und pflügen 500 meter
schutzstreifen und fünf kilometer
sperrzone errichten
tausende von menschen im grenzgebiet
werden ausgesiedelt ohne vorwarnung
fotografieren strengstens verboten
diese aufnahmen von einem westdeutschen
journalisten gedreht am stacheldrahtzaun
sind wahrscheinlich die einzigen die es
davon gibt
staatenlose und ausländer menschen die
polizeilich nicht gemeldet waren
vorbestrafte werden ausgesiedelt aber
sie sind nicht die einzigen
und die vierte gruppe und das ist
eigentlich die größte sind menschen die
tendenziell oder wirklich im widerspruch
zur antifaschistisch demokratischen
ordnung in der ddr standen wie es damals
hieß seiner familie gehört dazu rund
8400 menschen werden zwangs ausgesiedelt
sie kommen in andere teile der ddr und
dürfen nicht darüber reden familie
flüchtet über west berlin in die
bundesrepublik sein vater hier bei einem
besuch nach der wende hat die liebe zur
heimat an den sohn weitergegeben was ist
meine heimat und mir gefällt es hier
herrlich und meine eltern wollten
unbedingt sofort auch wieder her und
dann hab ich stehe natürlich geholfen so
gut es ging heute ist die innerdeutsche
grenze grünes band doch viele betroffene
familien kämpfen noch immer für eine
entschädigung und gegen das vergessen
und
jetzt der überblick heute über weitere
wichtige nachrichten und den hast du und
da beginnen wir mit dem verheerenden
zugunglück bei garmisch partenkirchen
jetzt ist klar dass es keine vermissten
mehr gibt laut polizei konnten auch die
letzten offenen fälle geklärt und die
toten identifiziert werden bei dem
unglück am freitag sind fünf menschen
ums leben gekommen darunter vier frauen
und ein junge im teenager alter mit
einem spezialkran begannen die
einsatzkräfte heute die waggons
abzutransportieren
und auch die ermittlungen gingen weiter
noch ist unklar warum der zug entgleiste
der sozialverband vdk hat angekündigt
gerichtlich gegen die energie pauschale
vorzugehen diese verstoße gegen den
gleichheitsgrundsatz erklärte die
vdk-vorsitzende bentele der bild am
sonntag
arme rentnerinnen und rentner aber auch
pflegende angehörige und mensch die
kranken oder elterngeld bekommen würden
leer ausgehen die energie pauschale von
300 euro ist teil des entlastungs paket
der bundesregierung sie wird nur an
einkommenssteuer pflichtige
erwerbstätige ausgezahlt
bei einem großbrand in einem container
lager im osten von bangladesch sind
mindestens 49 menschen ums leben
gekommen hunderte wurden verletzt das
feuer war in der nacht aus noch
unbekannter ursache ausgebrochen
mehrere explosionen erschwerten die
löscharbeiten erklärte die feuerwehr
auf dem betroffenen gelände werden auch
chemikalien gelagert
bei einem angriff auf eine katholische
kirche im südwesten nigeria sind
offenbar dutzende menschen getötet
worden während des pfingst
gottesdienstes sollen mehrere bewaffnete
die kirche in der stadt wo gestürmt
haben die genaue zahl der opfer ist
unklar bisher hat sich noch keine gruppe
zu dem anschlag bekannt
zum tennis der spanier rafael nadal hat
die french open gewonnen und das zum
vierzehnten mal so oft wie kein anderer
spieler der 36 jährige grand slam rekord
champion setzte sich im finale mit 6 2 3
6 3 und 6 0 gegen den norweger caspary
durch
die queen wirkt nicht so als sei sie
eine besondere freundin von
überraschungen zu ehren ihres 70
jubiläums auf dem thron hatte sie jetzt
dennoch einen ungewöhnlichen gast im
palast der ein wenig exzentrisch ist dem
die sympathien nur so zufliegen den man
durchaus eine legende nennen kann er hat
also ziemlich viel gemein mit der
jubilarin selbst auch die note ration
für alle fälle
[Musik]
hier
o
later
sehr britisch der film der humor
überhaupt dieser tag mit picknicks und
grillfesten zu ehren ihrer majestät und
mit dem gefühl bei den untertanen dass
da ein wechsel auf dem thron begonnen
hat ohne dass das offiziell wäre und man
groß darüber spricht also ebenfalls sehr
britisch diana zimmermann
lang lebe unsere edle königin als die
queen auf dem balkon auftauchte
sichtlich gerührt gab es kein halten
mehr aus voller brust sein die
riesenmenge auf der royal mail gott
schütze die königin
manche konnten vor begeisterung das
handy gar nicht mehr absetzen
sie sahen so großartig aus atemberaubend
so ein schöner tag die atmosphäre
sie nach 61 jahren heute zum ersten und
hoffentlich nicht letzten mal gesehen zu
haben hat mich sehr gerührt
ich liebe sie sie ist so niedlich ich
würde meine tasche stecken
bei einem gigantischen konzert vor dem
palast waren gestern abend neben vielen
anderen queen rod stewart und diana ross
aufgetreten die königlichen nachfahren
schwenken brav wie alle anderen den
jungen jack selbst gegner der monarchie
mussten zugeben dass bei dem viertägigen
spektakel für alle generationen etwas
dabei war heute zogen 10.000 musiker
tänzer und puppenmacher am palast vorbei
und mit ihnen szenen aus den sieben
jahrzehnten regentschaft der queen doch
die bombenstimmung zeigt nicht das ganze
bild die monarchie verliert jedes jahr
an zustimmung an der queen liegt das
kaum
ich könnte mir gut vorstellen dass queen
elizabeth auf die letzte königin ist und
ich finde dass wir dann ein futter eine
gute gelegenheit über eine republik
nachzudenken
ich erkenne an dass charles lange
gewartet hat aber ich hoffe er versteht
schnell dass die zukunft bei den
jüngeren liegt
der künftige könig war im laufe der
feierlichkeiten immer wieder für seine
mutter eingesprungen das geschah um die
96-jährige zu schonen aber auch so wird
spekuliert damit die briten ihn als
unausweichlich anerkennen musste
mami
der wenig populäre thronfolger bedankte
sich bei seiner mutter für ihren
lebenslangen einsatz
du lachst und weins mit uns am
wichtigsten aber du warst 70 jahre lang
für uns da und schreibt weiter
geschichte
filmgeschichte etwa
bei den olympischen spielen hatte die
queen dadurch begeistert dass sie als
unfassbar cooles bond-girl direkt zu der
eröffnungsfeier ins stadion absprang
auch der gestrige höhepunkt war ein
kleiner film in dem die jubilarin die
hauptrolle spielt mit königlichem humor
trinkt tee mit einer weiteren britischen
ikone paddington bär benimmt sich
daneben die
großmutter der nation sieht darüber
hinweg sie hat als regentin mutter und
großmutter schon ganz anderes gesehen
[Applaus]
everything
das würde keinen
[Musik]
und jetzt der blick auf die
wetteraussichten morgen eine mischung
aus sonne und wolken mit einzelnen
schauern im nordwesten und am alpenrand
vereinzelt auch gewitter bei einem teils
starkem südwestwind höchstwerte zwischen
18 und 27 grad am dienstag bei 16 bis 24
grad vor allem im süden und westen regen
teils gewittrig im nordosten
freundlicher auch danach wechselhaft bei
wenig temperaturänderungen es gibt ja
leute die man mit einem besonders
schönen schirm ins büro kommen
es lohnt sich in den nächsten tagen das
war unsere welt an diesem sonntag danke
fürs interesse wir sehen uns morgen
wieder wenn sie mit patches angenehm
haben
[Musik]